bang-bang lunch money time while Wall
Street's trying to get rich the rest of
us are just trying to get our lunch
money right I'm here with the beautiful
and intelligent Anthony Pellicano who is
wearing a black t-shirt Anthony welcome
to the polina show are you taking over
now yeah
did you enjoy doing that yeah lunch
money time on a Friday it's Friday
Friday remember Rebecca Black well while
she's trying to get rich to us nice
trying to get a little money right what
is going on in facebook land Facebook is
buying iffy start up or sorry gift
platform giffy for four hundred million
dollars does this settle the debate on
whether it's gif or Jif no it's always
been giffy or gif no I don't think it
has I think that the founder of gifs
calls them gifs but if he thinks that
does that make it gifs or does the
community get it aside that it's
actually a gift that's not really suck
like you create something you name it
something and then like the stupid
company takes in like just getting we're
gonna change we're gonna mispronounce
your products name and then they become
big and screw you found her well I'm
sure he he's perfectly fine giffy by the
way is screwed as well because it's
actually a fire sale they're not making
money on this deal why it's over 400
million dollars but the last valuation
was six hundred million dollars I can
guarantee you that the companies
involved here beta works leer HIPPA DFJ
GTV Lightspeed they all have
preferential treatment in the capital
stack meaning that they put in I think
150 million dollars total
so that first 150 million of the four
hundreds coming back to them they
recouped their their initial investment
that leaves 250 million dollars left and
then I bet you they own majority of the
company and therefore they then take all
of that and so if you're the founder of
giffy I bet you you're walking away
maybe with a couple million dollars but
this is not a positive well I
the founder of gif he should be thankful
because of four hundred million dollars
for literally gifts on a website I think
is more than generous disagree why do
you know what it means gifts small short
videos remind me of know hieroglyphics
remember what those are Neanderthals and
Homo sapiens used them yeah basically
the way that people communicated back in
the day was hieroglyphics they would
draw right they would create an image to
communicate an idea or a thought are you
saying that humans are simple I think
that human just as much as the world
changes the world doesn't change as well
and the way that we're communicating
today yeah sure there's a little
animated video but it's basically a
modern-day or digital form of a
hieroglyphic and so that is a an
important way to communicate just like
writing or speaking or anything else so
I wouldn't have very ask you can you can
ask whatever you want is your show now
Santa Claus because she look like she
looks like Miss Claus well she's from
the North Pole go ahead businesswoman
and mrs. Claus here um is this not a
missed opportunity for Twitter because
if you think about it I only use gifts
in text messages and Twitter I don't use
them on Facebook do you use Facebook no
not really
okay so that's more of a selection bias
than it is but but my question is is was
this a missed opportunity for Twitter
too we were to use all Facebook's gonna
do here is they probably bought some
engineering talent and they also
probably got some access to be able to
monetize the company right and now all
of a sudden they can take all of these
library of asset and bear away tomas
sites it'll make a four hundred dollar
acquisition look small but do you think
that Facebook will prevent Twitter from
using it on their platforms since
Facebook now owns giffy yeah maybe the
gift quality might go down but it's not
gonna be that big of a difference okay
what's going on with Jerome Powell my
favorite guy
yes your yo-yo friend do you want to do
the noise
I just wanted to get that out of the way
cuz Princeton we're printing baby
they're talking about print in three
trillion more that would be over five
trillion which if you'd remember from an
earlier episode of lunch money I said
they're gonna have to do five trillion
or more here we go what's he saying now
so basically jerry has changed his tune
if you remember he used to say he used
to say that we can't expect a v-shaped
recovery for the economy now he's saying
you know don't expect that basically
walking in with a net worth of over 50
million dollars please welcome him to
reality duh of course this isn't gonna
be as good as a recovery as they hope it
to be all you had to do was call small
business owner and say hey what are you
seeing they're gonna tell you that their
business sucks that they have no revenue
they're firing all their employees and
they don't know if they're gonna make it
out the other end of this thing but the
difference is people in the government
and in the Federal Reserve are looking
at economic data that economic data is a
lagging indicator so there's looking at
GDP growth they're looking at
unemployment all of these things are
going to happen after the situation
actually gets worse and so I think that
finally we're starting to see them
saying hey look this is not going to
recover like we thought it was by the
way kudos to him for publicly coming out
and saying this and starting to have a
realistic message to people because it's
just unfair to the average American to
continue to say everything's coming back
everything's coming back and playing
this confidence game when they know
that's not look actually gonna happen
maybe he's been watching lunch money hey
Jerry if you watching baby DM us well
that will get you educated real fast we
got all kinds of ideas what's going on
with McDonald's McDonald's is
celebrating its 80th birthday what do
you think about that happy birthday to
you happy birthday to me happy birthday
to the best restaurant in America happy
birthday to you are you happy I'm very
happy what are they doing to celebrate
um is wrong is Ronnie McDonald gonna run
around Ronnie's not anywhere to be found
at the moment but to celebrate their
kind of detailing what Dinah
we'll look like those as it as the
restaurants began reopening during the
corona virus pandemic including they're
telling franchise owners to put closed
signs on tables to promote social
distancing and they're gonna clean the
bathrooms every 30 minutes I mean those
are great ideas but I have a better idea
for McDonald what just fix the McFlurry
and ice cream machine and people will be
there in droves they'll be showing up
and they'll be like hey is the ice cream
machine working yes bang bang bang bang
bang let me get six Mick flurries Eminem
style Eagle Eminem's Oreos I would like
to report a crime I would like to report
a crime what you know I don't like I
don't like we are going to have a very
long discussion about this I'm the
psychopathy test this is a red flag not
like an ice cream I hate but you know
watch cremate she wait tonight I must
stay in a fry screams can I tell them
why I don't like why so I used to love
ice cream and I was like six did I
scream treat you badly well I'll tell
you what happened if you listen um so I
was at my grandparents house and I just
I loved ice cream so much I decided to
make my own so I took some like old ice
cream I found in the freezer and I like
put some salt and sugar and vinegar
literally whatever I could find and I
just still remember it was like this
like pink disgusting thing and none of
my family members wanted to try any of
it so to prove a point because I was a
stubborn little kid I ate all of it and
it was disgusting it was warm and it was
like awful so I I literally like threw
up for the next two days and so I
haven't a candy ice cream
I am so concerned for my safety right
now everyone you put salt and vinegar on
ice cream I don't know like I was trying
to be a scientist like a food scientist
stick to being miss Claus and stay out
of the kitchen with the the food
scientists out there what's going on
with Rockland by the way McDonald's if
I'm being completely honest they're
digital kiosk system he's going to be
leading that to is going to end up being
the standard across all fast
restaurants even post coronavirus yes
because eventually what you'll be able
to do is you won't actually have to
touch the screen it'll I be voice
activated or guests or gesture active oh
yeah so you can just walk up and you can
basically just talk to a robot right
like you love robots robot dog so if you
guys remember Boston Dynamics is that
really cool company cool or you know
terrifying they have these like humanoid
robots that jump and open doors and like
the robot dog opens the door for a dog
friend you know this is the scariest
thing in the world because the robot dog
is now patrolling like public parks and
stuff for social distancing the robot
overlords are here do you are you cool
with this I mean it's a really cute
looking robot um yeah until they put a
rifle on it and then it can shoot you
well okay hold on so there's there's a
human nearby who can do whatever
enforcement day decide is appropriate
after the dog has accosted you come out
somebody just picks the dog and says get
out of here back our freedom let's think
about that for a second so now we're
going from cops who by the way are
walking around New York City I don't see
a lot of them with mass tanin amount of
people and we're now gonna have robots
that have all sorts of ultra skills to
them so they've got night vision they
could have they could track your face
they could be feeding a live feed back
to somebody else they could be
processing all sorts of data they can
tract you they could literally kind of
put something on you what why you cool
with this like how do you reason with a
robot dog you don't you can't no you
just something to plug it looks like
Reese fries - head back let me give you
a little pet and as your pet ADIZ you
just unplug it right here yeah I'd be
aware they call it like they got it
people get mad when they go kill animals
about the people who are disconnecting
the robots but what about chappie well
chappie but they chopped off his arm
maybe chop off his arm that's bad if you
just disconnect them as far away it'd be
right
I mean it's usually imagine if we walked
went to Central Park and there's a bunch
of robot dogs run
around and they were literally keeping
people away from each other like what
happens if they started chasing would
you run yeah I would run but get you um
I know that's why I would run and
probably climb something um but it's
suit it's like a super dog basically
just jump up there I was talking to the
stre searcher him and she said that this
like um there's this phenomenon that
this oh my god don't be spilling your
water um you're doing science science so
she said that the second that something
moves people tend to what is it gold not
humanize it but like anthropomorphize
anyway they tend to develop feelings
towards things that are moving even if
they're robots so if you have a Roomba
you probably kind of associate like it's
like a like a real thing kind of like
you have like feelings ahead yeah so if
you kick it keep it oh my god I just
kicked you know some I'm moving yeah I'm
worried about the robots feelings not at
all but I will say that they did name
the robotic dog from Boston Dynamics
spot which is a way to try to make it
seem cuter right they painted in a
bright color like they're doing all
these things to try to make it less
scary but the reason why they're doing
is because this [ __ ] is scary
they literally have robots now they can
call it a dog all they want but it is a
robot that is patrolling public parks
where is it in Singapore I believe they
are patrolling public parks and trying
to enforce social distancing the
dystopian world is the robot isn't
really enforcing it Singapore it's just
giving people information and
encouraging them hello I am from the
government and I'm here to help
come on wake up people get the robots
out of here we don't need them enforcing
social distancing I like technology I'm
a big fan but this is pretty ridiculous
what's going on with tick-tock I would
like to get a robot that would enforce
you over here in the apartment to do
stuff okay so um tik-tok therapy
therapists are going on tick-tock and
literally offering like therapeutic
advice and tips in 15-second
what are they saying breathe well I
could be a therapist on take like
breathe or how about this one put your
phone down by the way great for them
like super excited I hope it works but I
think so you have to you have to kind of
think about like you have to go where
the people are I didn't I wrote an
article about all these personal finance
people giving personal finance advice on
tick tock because that's where the next
generation is I agree no look I think
this is cool like they should do it I'm
just wondering what kind of advice are
they actually giving in 15 seconds
well they're probably like tips you know
like sleep eight hours and clean your
bathroom drink water
breathe put your phone down go outside
just kidding don't go outside
hey um see I didn't want to tell the
people how I changed your life from the
sleeping I I'm big sleep guy now
I used to sleep for out legitimately
used to sleep for hours like a
psychopath and then plane it was like
hey this ain't gonna fly no more is how
I did it because he wouldn't listen to
me of course if I said you need to sleep
eight hours but then when I got him an
Apple watch for your birthday or
something and there's an app called
sleep watch and it becomes like a
competition so if he doesn't sleep eight
hours he's like oh my god like my watch
so if you turn it into a competition and
you have somebody competitive it works
let me translate for you she put a
tracking device on me so that she could
track if I slept eight hours or not she
could spin this however she wants I got
a tracking device there the robots are
after me
by the way tick tock is very addicting
polina has been showing me videos oh you
were watching it without yeah and I like
went on it I was like whoa this is like
kind of cool kind of fun like I felt
like I was in a new I felt like I was
the guy with the dad jeans and the white
Nikes showing up to the ball game and
everyone's like so the old guys here
this is kind of sad but also kind of
funny like because we're together all
day every day to get some privacy he'll
go to the bathroom oh yeah then and not
every guy but I just hear like doo doo
doo doo doo yeah every guy knows this
tick tock
listen if you want privacy just I gotta
go
bathroom I just go in there sometimes I
just sit on the floor like I got a
little breather in here you know I might
need to start putting snacks in there
somewhere so then you don't even know
I'm eatin snacks while I'm just hanging
out why okay well we'll discuss later
maybe I'll put an ice cream machine in
there from McDonald's what would you do
if you came home and I had a McFlurry
machine I'm literally like I have to
clean the before some you know a cupcake
wrapper if I don't show up on Monday
guys just go look for me in the bathroom
I have alcohol candy and an ice-cream
machine from McDonald's I'll be ready to
rock and roll and my phone a little
tick-tock all right uh lunch money time
it is Friday so you know what that means
$100 is being given out we are going to
anyone who takes this URL for the
episode tweet it include the hashtag
lunch money you have to include the
hashtag lunch money so that we can find
it and tell us what is one thing that
made you laugh this week we will give
one person $100 well let's you know on
Monday who won but take the URL tweet it
hashtag lunch money
what made you laugh this week you get
$100 if we pick you and if you do not
have Twitter we are trying to come up
with a solution as to how to do this in
a efficient way we don't have one yet
but that is coming we are working on it
nope can't do that from reasons that we
will discuss later but if we can
actually one other thing that I would
love for you guys to do is a bunch of
you watch this show and I know because
you leave comments but you're not
subscribed to the channel so subscribe
to the channel so you can get all the
videos come on you crazy subscribe to
subscribe subscribe because if you
didn't subscribe how else would you know
why I don't like ice cream would you
look perfectly valid non psychopath
reason do you want to know what I'm
excited about what I think in the next
two weeks we're getting close when we
started this show used to get zero views
than a hundred views than 500 views than
a thousand views whatever if you go back
look this for the early ones but we now
are consistently crossing 10,000 views
per per episode so and I
the next two weeks we're gonna start
crossing 20,000 but is that because
people like it or is it because they're
coming from my jokes you know why no
because I must ask you a question wait
one more fun fact before we close this
out you'll notice so lunch money we
actually tried to record one time back
pre coronavirus days and it didn't end
well because I got mad at him and it was
terrible and yeah do you know why she
got mad at me cuz I was dropping the
truth I hit her with so much truth she
was disoriented she was just like
looking around like oh my god there's so
much truth in here I got to leave and
she got upset cuz I have friends in the
comments alright guys that's it for
lunch money take the URL go post it on
Twitter use hash tag lunch money we'll
pick one of you to give you a hundred
bucks so you can go out to dinner with
your friends family donate it do
whatever you want with 100 bucks we
appreciate you watching well while she's
trying to get rich the rest of us just
trying to get their lunch money right
and don't forget the robots are here
baby